from a film distributors POV would you
say that short films don't matter they
don't count they they do count I mean
there isn't a builder essentially
because if you can't make a good short
film how you make good feature Lake your
short film doesn't look good then what
how you gonna persuade somebody that if
it's your first feature hey this is
gonna look good they do count however I
think today's things have changed it's
it's cheaper to shoot a film then it was
there no I think of shot digital now
versus back in the 90s and before
everything was like film it was a lot
more expensive so making a short film
back then was a lot more expensive so
now it's kind of you can make a feature
film for relatively cheap and you might
not have the best like lighting or some
attire for yourself there the camera
package or something but you can choose
relatively cheap so with that being in
mind making a feature you know is that's
kind of like I think a lot of people's
calling cards now versus a short film
used to be kind of like your way of
building a big resume now it's kind of
like well a feature films cheaper to
make so there are a lot of careers and
people are in the business are expecting
you to make a feature and have a body
work if you're asking for financing for
another future they're expecting to see
features not so much shorts under your
belts but they do count absolutely yeah
how many shorts did you make before um
the Mason brothers like four or in come
on and when you were a little kid were
you were you filming stuff - no no you
weren't one of those kids that were
taking things apart and you know you
always hear about that no okay
you know all into this into the
filmmaking and and everything really all
right and so you had another course for
yourself but you decided to come out
here and you had people that loved you
back home that wanted you to stay it
sounds like yeah yeah of course I mean
it's a huge leap yeah it's a big move
big change but that's what I wanted so I
came out here
when after it
you